let me ask you guys a question here's a
question for you so i go to uh
maestros i'm having dinner there with
jen and it's her birthday and i our
waiter comes i'm talking to the waiter
so tell me uh where are you from he says
well i grew up in san diego but i lived
in san francisco and now i'm over here i
saw fantastic i said how do you like it
in florida she said yeah it is what it
is just where are you from i said i
lived in la 20 some years i lived in
dallas for five years and i've been in
florida for one year how do you like
florida i said i love it what do you
love about florida i said policies
freedom
let me do what i want to do low taxes no
taxes low regulation lifestyle etc etc i
like that also about texas but it wasn't
the lifestyle he says okay walks away
then he comes back
and i said let me ask you a crazy
question here says yes yes and he's now
he's quick with me
i said is it fair to say that you lean
more left than you do right
yes i do
i said how do you handle it with your
family we have one rule that we follow
what's that
we don't talk politics
just we just don't talk politics that's
how we keep our families together so so
here's a q but you got to realize we've
heard this for the longest time you
don't talk politics you don't talk
religion you don't talk this when you're
doing business or with your family isn't
that a way of copping out and not
willing to have the tough conversation
that you need to have what are your
thoughts yeah for sure i mean those
should actually be the conversations
that you that happen first and foremost
around the family dinner table i mean
that's that's the actual real safe space
is is for parents to talk about these
issues with their children for children
to be able to ask questions and not
think about the ramifications that might
happen in the classroom or with their
friends but to ask their parents the
awkward questions that they might have i
mean this is this is something of course
that's lost i mean this goes back to the
whole deeper issue of the nuclear family
right because parents should be
indoctrinating their children they
should be passing on their values their
principles their religious views their
politics to their children and then when
their children are adults then you can
say okay do i want to continue as an
adult in following these these values
that i was taught but yeah i mean
students students in school in college
it's actually shocking sometimes
what they don't know
because they haven't heard anything
except for what tom was saying that
speech is violence if the speech offends
someone well liz if if trans is the
number one issue that they bring up
what's number two three four
oh what are what do you care about the
youth the gen z my youngest sister is uh
19 she's in college so she's right at
that age she is right at that age yeah
they care i mean they care about they
don't care about fiscal issues because
they don't they don't have any money
they're not working so i just started
yet
it's really interesting too if you think
about it the government just gave you
two trillion dollars in checks it's
going to happen somehow you didn't have
to worry about it is it climate change
is it they're very fearful of climate
change one thing i think is interesting
to note though is we are setting up
their generation for this incredible
financial failure not even because of
all the spending which is obvious but
because of how we're teaching them
fiscal irresponsibility with college so
we send them off to college and these
colleges cost 20 30 40 50 000 a year
they come out at 22 years old with
hundreds of thousands of dollars in debt
and yet then we tell them don't don't
spend what you don't have live live
within your means and this is just
completely opposite of how we've
culturally forced them to go to these
institutions in order to be successful
but i'm sorry go ahead oh let me talk
about the climate change thing for a
second there are a significant number of
gen zers who actually suffer clinical
anxiety
and insomnia they have sleep problems
because they're worried about climate
change because they believe the folks
that say oh the earth is going to be 12
years yeah the 11 the aoc 11 years and
the earth is totally gone well when you
hear that and you're only 18 years old
and for your entire life you're thinking
you're going to be dead in 10 years
wouldn't you also have the same
nerve-wracking situation going on if
you're 17 18 19 years old and that's all
you've ever known if it's all i've ever
known sure but i mean that goes back to
i mean that's why pat does what he does
that's why i do what i do because there
needs to be a counter narrative of
reality these kids want to hear the
truth that's the thing they want to hear
what's real they are hungry for facts
they are hungry for knowledge they've
just only been fed one side of it which
is why you know my independent venture
pat's independent venture are very
successful because people actually do
really really want to hear um the facts
of what's going on so i mean there
shouldn't be a 17 year old or an 18 year
old or a 19 year old in our country
who's only heard that the earth is going
to end in 11 years and that they
shouldn't have children and that we
should ban airplanes and red meat they
should say oh i hear that from one side
the other side says this now let me
think for myself you know well whenever
i watch tom talk to his kids he's always
talking issues with his kids always
talking he'd read this article read that
article what do you think about this
what do you think about that they're
always going back and forth right and
they'll send the notes to him and he'll
show it to me look what bailey just said
look what brooke just said look how she
processed this right remember when we
had rfk on uh first time around when we
uh kennedy i asked some questions i said
so tell me about some of the kennedy
traditions what are some of the kennedy
traditions that you guys have he says
every night at the dinner table
our our father he would start a debate
he would say what do you think about
drugs why are they bad i said your dad
would say about jesus yeah he says why
are drugs bad to use so you got to be
kidding me says no then he would say
what's wrong with me using drugs
what's wrong with me drinking as much as
i want what's wrong with rich people are
rich people greedy he said it was
constantly debate constantly debate
i put the fault of this and this is not
gonna you know some people are not gonna
be happy about this
when kids are panicking about climate
change you know whose responsibility
that is the head of the household they
don't have these conversations with them
okay the head of the household needs to
in today's climate if you really want to
raise your kids to be strong leaders
today the head of the household has to
be very aware of what's going on and be
willing to have these conversations with
them because if you don't and they go
you're essentially handing your kids
over to teachers to raise them with a
mindset that they want to raise them
rather than you yeah you're going to say
work hard do this be a good person go to
church whatever some of the things
parents say but you got to get a little
bit deeper i think these conversations
need to happen
what happens when you when you teach
your kids what you want and as let's say
you indoctrinate them into your values
et cetera et cetera et cetera then you
send them off for four years and they
come back completely different and their
values have done a complete 180. but i'm
not indoctrinating in my specifically
in my uh
values i'm indoctrinating in a way of
processing issues not necessarily values
i'm telling you what are my my values
and principles here's what we live by
the david family lives by lead respect
improve love we don't bully we don't get
bully we pray for courage wisdom
tolerance understanding this is what we
do as a family this is what i encourage
you to do but you you ask the why
question why do you like this morning
dylan he's reading a book he comes up to
me he's reading a world cup book and in
the world cup book he reads about a
story of hitler that in 1933 world cup
1932 whatever the world cup was hitler's
aspiration was to be like mussolini he
says dad do you realize what this hitler
every book i'm reading about hitler is
terrible so what do you think about this
guy do that this this guy's a terrible
guy if he did this i said why don't you
go figure out why he hated you so much
so i should go figure i said go research
you find out for yourself and tell me
but it's not saying
you know you're you're feeding and then
saying go find out and then come back
i'm teaching you to go find out for
yourself yeah it's critical thinking
yeah you're teaching this you're not
teaching
this is the way we are and that's it now
you're you're gonna have a kid fight you
later on okay you're teaching them how
to process issues so if you enjoyed this
little segment from the podcast click
over here to watch the entire podcast
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so take care everybody
[Music]